soil Bloom is the image of success he's
a former pro baseball player Creator
entrepreneur and investor but he told me
the one thing more motivating and more
valuable than money I think that money
can create intensity like oh I'm gonna
make a million dollars this year and
it's going to make me focus a ton and
I'm like really grind it out and you
know put in all these hours and do this
I'm gonna get the bonus or I'm gonna
make my YouTube channel big whatever but
the consistency and your ability to show
up every single day when you feel good
when you don't feel good when you're
tired when it's a holiday when your
family has something and you have to
miss it like that consistency only comes
from enjoying it enjoying the ups and
downs like it's not always going to be
good you're going to put things out
you're proud of and they're not going to
go anywhere it's really hard to beat
someone that does that like it's just
very hard to durably beat someone that
just keeps getting up keeps showing up
the enjoyment is so key to creating that
consistency